PROFESSOR: Distinguished
members of the city council--
good morning, and thank
you for meeting with me.
As you know, we will be working
with a municipal planning
agency in the drafting of the
new master plan for the city.
I address you today because as
a first step in the process,
our team requires the council's
full support in what we believe
is the best planning framework
to achieve the city's two
primary objective--
economic development
in the long term and
short-term pollution reduction.
We are aware that
not just the city,
but a different
set of stakeholders
must work together
in order to counter
the impacts of the regional
wastewater treatment plant
and the runoff from
agricultural activities
upstream that currently
discourage investment
in the city.
With this in mind, we
propose a combination
of community planning assisted
by consensus building exercises
as a pivot for design and
implementation of the new plan.
I will spend the
next few minutes
explaining how
participation will
enhance the value of the plan,
highlight aspects of community
building for this
space, and conclude
with a particular focus
we will use for your city.
Having worked over 15
years in planning efforts
and over 20 different
cities, my experience
has taught me that meaningful
public participation
is the seed of successful
implementation.
Many times I have seen
sophisticated master plans
neglecting this fact
and as a result,
waste of taxpayers' money
because the community perceives
the method as being unfair.
When plans do not connect
assessment and design
with public will,
this often ends up
hindering economic development
by giving way to social unrest
and expensive delays in plans.
Money spent on a planning
process instead of a planning
report can truly be
called investment
in the public interest.
Participation has a
triple bottom line.
It brings additional skills
to the planning table,
it provides alternative
insights to diminish
risk of economic
failure, and generates
learning and
cooperation networks
that transcend the plan itself.
We will pursue these benefits
through a community planning
exercise where a neutral body
will map the main stakeholder
groups surrounding
our polluted river.
Peers within the groups
will choose a representative
that will participate in
having an informed discussion
about the alternatives for
environmental improvement
of the city.
I am aware that public
participation is not
deeply ingrained in local
institutional culture.
In fact, initial
conversations with the staff
indicate some reserve.
This is not unusual
because of narrow
and procedural applications
of public presentation
elsewhere have definitely
set a poor precedent.
In the absence of
proper management,
public hearings
and consultations
are often inefficient and only
yield superficial discussions.
Other times the are held hostage
by the best organized groups.
With such references,
I find it to be
very understandable
for any of you
to take public participation
with some degree of skepticism.
In order to address
these concerns,
my team and I will
combine community planning
with consensus
building exercises.
In comparison to
other strategies,
this framework will
use a mutual mediator
that will add credibility and
efficiency to the process.
Strive for plurality instead of
statistical representativeness,
which is not only
expensive but also
ensures that there is a level
playing field preventing
majority rules.
The mediator will curate
participating groups early
in the process
ensuring a fair voice
that reflects your
economic concerns
and also that ensures that
the rich, racial diversity
of the city is
represented at the table.
Finally, this framework will
guarantee recommendations
that are feasible because
all will be required
to be grounded on a
technical expertise provided
by an advisory committee.
Due to little experience with
participation in the city,
the outline of the
process we proposed
is similar to the one we
very successfully used
in Hampton, Virginia, where
there was emphasis in learning.
Participants will be trained
about river pollution,
the implications of
green investment,
and different alternatives to
promote economic development.
This will enable full and
detailed participation
in the discussion on the
proposed Will alternatives.
We are not asking you to give
up authority in this matter.
You remain the ultimate
decision-makers
to weigh these proposals
on their merit.
This exercise is
for, and you will
have an unprecedented insight to
a range of the concerns of all
of your constituents.
I do request, however,
your endorsement
to a public commitment
that considers
the inclusion of the
negotiated recommendations
in the new plan.
I conclude by pointing
out that this method is
relatively inexpensive
as compared to others.
An assessment does not
need much time or money.
Furthermore, investment
and consensus
yields great
legitimacy and trust.
And with this, the
greatest opportunity
to achieve fair, efficient
wise and stable commitments
to come and go.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]